who here has one amazing Superstar
person who works for you imagine if you
had four of them how easy would life be
you make a ton of money here's what's
crazy the difference between small
businesses and big businesses is how
many a players they have and so what
happens is most small business owners
hire a lot of people get lucky one
sticks actually works their ass off at a
fair rate and you're like ah man if I
had six more sandras right I'd be good
to go the thing is is that big business
owners maintain a higher level or a
lower tolerance for mediocrity and so
they actually do keep looking until they
find six Andreas and then it does become
too easy for them to kill it because I
got six sandrew how can I lose